we're at a low point in the
cryptocurrency space from a shallow
analysis perspective or maybe in a
deeper sense if you can enlighten me do
you think Bitcoin will rise again yes do
you think you'll go uh to take on
Fiat you know to go over a million
dollars to go to these Heights I mean I
think it's possible and the reason I
think it's possible is I think a lot of
things might go to a million dollars
because this place is inflation right
it's an important point right it's a
very important Point yes because you're
seeing essentially
yes right sure the choke pointing on
energy is pushing up prices across the
board for a lot of things the supply you
know China's not doing us any favors
with the covid uh lockdowns
um Putin's not doing the world any
favors with this with this giant War
um there's a lot of bad things happening
in the physical world right you know you
have
I mean when China Russia and the US are
all and Europe is you know like there's
folks who are just insane about degrowth
and they're against
um you know they're they're they're
they're pushing for burning coal and
wood right so a lot of prices are going
up in a really foundational and
fundamental way and um with that said
also the dollar is in some way
strengthening against certain other
things because a lot of other countries
are dying harder right
um you know and you've got riots in Sri
Lanka and riots and Panama and riots in
you know all these places right so it's
it's very complicated because you've got
multiple different Trends going in the
same way you're you're Bitcoin Maximus
would just say infinity over 21 million
and so therefore you print all the
dollars there's only 200 million
Bitcoins so Bitcoin goes to Infinity but
it can be something where lots of other
currencies die and the dollar is
actually exported via stable coins okay
um but I do think it still moves Fiat
still moves somehow into the
cryptocurrencies yeah yeah it's I think
it's kind of like Microsoft where and
windows is still around right I'm
actually still around still uh you know
multi 100 billion dollar company it
doesn't mean it he doesn't mean it don't
worry all my machines are windows are
they still boot yeah okay okay I don't
know a single Mech really okay that you
are unusual on that yeah that's um so at
least for hours it's not an ideology
just convenience fine I mean they
actually now post out there they do make
some good stuff right like uh Microsoft
teams is good right like there's a lot
of incredible stuff and UCO has done a
lot of innovative things like GitHub
yeah then we built this in acquisition
but still it's not giving credit for the
acquisition the pivoting of vision and
motivations and uh focus and all that
kind of stuff anyway yes Microsoft does
an analogy metaphor for something well
yeah so basically just like you know
they didn't need a turnaround but they
are they didn't endure to the present
day they didn't die from Google app I
mean for the massive attacks on them
they didn't die they are less powerful
but they make more money right yes and
um
I think that might be something that I
mean our best case scenario is the use
establishment or CCP has more power over
fewer people
okay I see and so you know but you can
exit if you if you're there you're kind
of knuckling under or whatever but you
can exit right and so I mentioned the uh
those three polls CCP is obviously a
billion people 1.4 aligned under the
digital Yuan and so on right nyt is the
entire you know it's it's the tech
companies it's the US dollar it is this
session and then crypto capital is
everybody else but I actually think that
over time
that third world is web 3 this time and
that's the third poll and that's India
and it's Israel and it's lots of
American conservatives and left
Libertarians and Libertarians and it's
also lots of Chinese liberals all the
folks who are trying to get out of China
because you know the like the you know
it's become so Nationalist and crazy and
difficult for capitalism and so if you
take basically non-establishment
Americans on both left and right okay
the the you know the bottom two
quadrants in the political Compass I
talked about you take the liberal
Chinese you take the Israelis and the
Indians why because they don't both of
them are have a lot of tech Talent right
they're the number one and number two
demographics for Tech founders
and they want to while they are
generally sympathetic to the West right
and they're more ties to the West they
also are more cautious about national
interests rather than just starting
fights you know where that's how they
would think about it right they just you
know India thinks is a poor country
Israel thinks of itself as a small
country and so therefore it needs to not
just get in every fight just for the
sake of it and so need to maintain a
cautious distance with China but not
like do what Pelosi is doing and try and
start like a big thing okay
I think Israel is similar where it's
maintaining diplomatic relations with
China it's more friendly towards China
than the US's Indian Israel I think are
two sovereign states that have a lot of
globally mobile tech talent that
obviously have ties to the West with the
large diaspora that are hard to demonize
you know in around the sense of
willing to argue on the internet
let's put it like in English right it's
very important and
um them plus enough Americans plus
enough Chinese can set up another poll
that is not for Cold War or military
confrontation but for peace and trade
and freedom and so on and so forth right
that's the center
as opposed to the you know left of the
you know the the woke American U.S
establishment or the right of the ultra
nationalist CCP right that's what I
think about now what I would say here is
the reason I think these are the kind of
the three polls you can argue against
this right you can say it's unipolar
World America is totally dominant that's
one argument you could say it's a
bipolar world it's just the US versus
China no no everybody else will have to
be forced to align with one or the other
jayashanker you know actually explicitly
rejected this he's like look there's a
billion people in India it's coming up
on it will eventually be like the number
three economy it's on the rise
he's got the history and culture he
thinks he's entitled to have India's
Intel to have its own side right in such
a thing it's a funny way of putting it
right yeah but it's also true and uh so
you could say it's unipolar you can say
it's bipolar you could say it's just
multi-polar and everybody is kind of
their you know India Israel these groups
are out there but I actually think it's
going to be tripolar the reasons
tripolar is these three pools are the
groups that have enough media and money
and scale and whatnot to really kind of
be self-consistent civilizations
obviously China's like the vertically
integrated like apple or whatever just
like a stable ideology a stable ideology
that's right right obviously the you
know the books have control of lots of
Institutions they've got the US
establishment and they've got the tech
companies they've got the media
companies and so on but crypto is
basically everybody else and crucially
crypto has inroads in China and America
where it's hard to demonize it as
completely foreign because there's many
many many huge proponents of the
Universalist values of crypto in America
and China because it is
true Global rule of law and free speech
and you know so on it is genuinely
Universalist in a way where America can
no longer be you know the number one
rule of the rules-based order is
America's always number one and China
doesn't even pretend to maintain a rules
disorder right yes whereas for all those
countries that don't want to either be
dominated by the U.S media corporations
that can or social media that can just
censor Trump nor do they want to be
dominated by China this is an attractive
alternative a platform they can make
their own right so that's where I think
you know I wrote an article on this in
foreign policy on um here here's two
articles that talk about this a little
bit it's called great protocol politics
and then here's another one on these
sort of domestic thing Bitcoin is
civilization for Barry Wise okay but I
want to just come up the stack a little
bit and just return to that original
point which I diverged on which was why
I gave the whole example of how uh
we got into China because I talked about
how China had gone from communist
capitalists and letting people have just
a share of what they owned right with
social media
we're still in kind of the Communist era
of social media almost where whatever
you earn on social media like Google
takes its cut Twitter takes 100 you're
nothing for all your tweets or anything
like that not only do you have do you
earn nothing
um you might get a little rev share on
Tick Tock or YouTube you can do okay
right but not only do you earn either
nothing or a little bit you have no
digital property rights even more
fundamentally you are at the just the
whim of a giant Corporation can hit a
button and everything you work for over
Years Gone okay that is even if that is
quote the current state of events the
State of Affairs rather that is not the
right balance of power
to be able to unperson somebody at the
touch of a key and take away everything
in their digital world when we're living
more and more in the digital world we
need to check on that power and the
check on that power is crypto and it's
property rights and it's
decentralization right then when I say
digital especially in decentralization I
mean
your money and your digital property is
by default yours and there has to be a
due process to for someone to take that
away from you everything all work is
online all your money is online your
presence is online that can just be
taken away from you with a with the
Press of a key that just gives you know
bad governments bad corporations so much
power that that's wrong right that's why
I'm a medium and long-term Bull on
crypto simply because to check on this
thing and that if you think about in
terms of just abstract decentralizations
one thing but you think about in terms
of property rights it's quite another
and um
now what that also means is once you
have property rights and you have
decentralized social media it'll be like
the explosion of trade that happened
after China went from communist
capitalist literally billions of people
around the world are no longer giving
everything to the collective they own
the teeth in their head now finally
okay is it funny right so you're Lex
friedman.eath you own it the keys are on
your computer the bad part is of course
they can get hacked or something like
that then you can deal with that with
social recovery there's rates of
securing keys but the good part is ta-da
uh you actually have property rights in
the Hernando de Soto sense you have
something you own ownership digital
ownership it's the cloud is great but
crypto gives you some of the
functionality of the cloud
while also having some of the
functionality offline world where you
have the keys so it's a v it's a V3
right it's you know it's continuous
theme right the V1 was offline I've got
a key I own it I have de facto control
V2 is the cloud someone else manages it
for me it's hosted I get collaboration
so on V3 is the chain where you combine
aspects of those right you have the
global state of the cloud but you have
the local permission and controlling of
the private key okay so that's why I'm a
medium to long term Ultra Bull on crypto
and I've actually there's a podcast I
gave with a Simco where I talked through
how crypto actually doesn't just go
after Finance so it's gold and it's wire
transfers and it's crowdfunding and it's
all a finance with D5 but it's actually
also search and it's social and it's
messaging it's actually even operating
systems
um and uh and eventually cloud and
whatnot talk about that briefly yeah
yeah if you can briefly see social how
broad you see the effect of crypto so
first crypto is fundamentally a new way
of building back-end systems right so if
you think about how big a deal it was to
go from at T's corporate Unix to Linux
it's permissionless right when you went
from as much as I admire a lot of the
stuff that you know Sam Altman and Greg
Brockman have done at open AI I mean
they're phenomenal in terms of research
they've pushed the envelope forward I
give them a ton of credit right still it
was great to see stable diffusion out
there which was open source AI right and
so from a developer from a power user
standpoint whenever you have the
unlocked version like an unlocked cell
phone it's always going to be better
right so
the um what crypto gives you obviously
it's every Financial thing in the world
you can do stocks bonds Etc it's not
just like the internet wasn't just a
channel it wasn't like radio and TV and
internet it was internet radio and
internet TV and internet this and
internet that everything was the
internet all media became the internet
crypto is not an asset class it's all
asset classes it's crypto stocks and
crypto bonds Etc in a real sense like
private property arguably didn't exist
in the same way before crypto
international law didn't exist before
crypto how is how are you going to do a
deal between Brazil and Bangladesh
um if a Brazilian company wants to you
know acquire a Bangladeshi company they
usually have to set up a us adapter in
between because otherwise what are the
tax or the you know other obligations
between the two you set up a us adapter
or a Chinese adapter to go between them
but now that Brazilian unboxing Edition
can go peer-to-peer because they're
using the blockchain right they can
agree on a system of law that is
completely you know International and
that's code so each party can diligence
it without speaking Portuguese and
bengalia right so that's why I am a
long-term Bull on crypto I just
described the the finance case let me go
through the others right social so
you have the private keys for your ens
you have apps like forecaster you um
basically have decentralized social
media where there's different variants
some you just log in with your crypto
username others the entire social
network and all the likes and posts are
on chain like DSO but uh but there's
several different versions right search
Once uh you know once you realize
um block explorers are an important
stealth threat to search they're very
high traffic sites like blockchain.com
and either scan that Google is just
totally slept on they don't have a block
Explorer you don't have to do anything
in terms of trading or anything like
that Google does not have a block
Explorer why they don't think of it as
search but it is search it's absolutely
searched it's a very important kind of
search engine and once you have crypto
social you have you now show that you're
not just indexing in a block Explorer
like uh on-chain transactions but on
chain Communications
okay so now you suddenly see oh the
entire Social Web that Google couldn't
index It could only index a worldwide
web and not the Social Web now it's
actually the on chain signed web because
every post is digitally signed it's a
new set of signals it's way easier to
index than either the World Wide Web or
the Social Web because it's open in
public so this is a total disruptive
thing to search in the medium term
because the new kind of data sets Index
right
so that's how it's a threat to social to
search it is a threat to messaging why
because or it's disrupt eventually
because the ens name as I mentioned is
like a universal identifier you can send
encrypted messages between people that's
a better primitive to base it on you
know WhatsApp is just claiming that
they're end to end encrypted but with an
ens name or with a crypto name you can
be provably auditably end to encrypted
because you're actually sending it back
and forth right because the private key
is local right that itself given how
important that is right you know you
could man in the middle signal or
Whatsapp because there's a server there
right if you have you know so end-to-end
encrypted messaging will happen and with
payments and all this other stuff okay
so you get the crypto messaging apps you
get uh operating systems why well the
frontier of operating systems I mean
look you know Windows uh Linux and Mac
OS have been around forever but if you
actually think about you know what is a
blockchain
well there's operating systems there's
web browsers a blockchain is the most
complicated thing since an operating
system or whatever is because it's a
kind of operating system why it's got
you know something like ethereum has an
evm it's got a programming language it's
got an ecosystem where people monetize
on it they build front-end apps and they
build back-end apps they interoperate
between each other this is a frontier of
operating systems research people
haven't thought of it that way right
it's also the frontier of a lot of
things in databases
um you will get a crypto LinkedIn where
there's zero knowledge proofs of various
credentials okay uh basically every
single web 2 company I can probably come
up with a web 3 variant of it right like
ethereum is I mean and this is high
praise for both parties but ethereum is
like the crypto stripe prior to the
Webster stripe and you will
um you will see versions of everything
else that are like this
but you know I kind of described uh
search social messaging operating
systems the phone right Salon is doing a
crypto phone why do you want that again
digital property apple is was talking
about running some script to find if
people were having you know csam like CH
you know child porn or whatever on their
on their phones right and even nyt
actually reported that uh like Google
ran something like this and found false
positive some guy had to take a photo of
a kid for our you know medical diagnosis
it got false you know falsely flagged I
see Sam he lost access to his account
total nightmare imagine just getting
locked out of your Google account which
you're so dependent on right as more and
more of your Digital Life Goes online
you know is it really that much
ethically different if it's the Chinese
state that locks you out or an American
corporation
right basically it's operationally very
similar you just have no recourse you're
unpersoned right so the crypto phone
becomes like insanely important because
you have a local set of private keys
this was the keys to your currency and
your passport and your services and your
life right so like become something you
just hold on you with your person at all
times like your normal phone you might
have backups and stuff but you know the
crypto phone is an insanely important
thing okay and so that's search that's
social that's messaging that's
um operating systems that's a phone
that's a lot right there yeah that's
beautiful